[Musique]
la folie de l'i phone les passionnés de
nouvelles technologies le connaissent
déjà il s'agit d'un téléphone d'un
portable avec de nouvelles applications
et il est mise en vente aujourd'hui en
france alors téléphone du futur ou
dernier gadget à la mode chacun se fera
son idée en tout cas c'est arrivé cette
mise en vente suscitent des mouvements
de foule alors qu'il faut tout de même
compter 400 euros minimum jean-paul
chapelle frédérick basile
[Applaudissements]
18h30 sur les champs elysées
plus de 2000 personnes
le sacrifice 11h02 que trois heures
d'attentes pour être parmi les premiers
à l'arborer comme un trophée
399 euros + 49 euros par mois minimum
mais un téléphone comme les autres
baladeur musical albums photos que l'on
feuillette grâce à un écran tactile
et l'accès à internet illimité même le
pdg de france télécom s'amuse à jouer
les démonstrateurs c'est comme si vous
aviez une peau élastique vous tirer
dessus c'est la grande et pour avoir
l'exclusivité de ce petit bijou orange a
accepté c'est une première de verser une
partie de ses revenus à apple sans doute
30% effectivement il ya un partage de
revenus le détail je vous le donnerai
pas ce que c'est le secret du contrat
j'ai très envie de venir chez pas le
droit de vous le dire
cela étant la raison pour laquelle je
fais ça c'est parce que c'est l'union de
deux marques qui sont les premières
mondiales chacune dans leur domaine
autres concessions arrachées par apple
l'américain aura accès au client final
pour me vendre des musiques pour
commencer des perspectives juteuse pour
apple certainement coûteuse pour les
abonnés on peut acheter de la musique
directement en appuyant sur un sur un
bouton d'un bout de doigt comme ça je
paye comme ça une nouvelle chanson sur
internet le piège du téléphone devenu
supermarché une source de profit qui a
déjà donné des idées à la concurrence
samsung blackberry ou le dernier nokia
offre un accès internet deux fois plus
rapide que l'iphone pour 200 euros de
moi
[Musique]